merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur général Madame et Monsieur
laporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord peut-être un mot pour
vous dire le plaisir que je vais vous
retrouver pour cette audition début 2023
autour de la réforme des retraites et de
ce texte avant d'en venir au principal
caractéristiques du texte à ce qui fait
son identité et ce qui fait aussi les ce
que sont les priorités du gouvernement à
la matière je voudrais peut-être revenir
d'un mot sur la méthode pour dire que
cette réforme telle que nous la
présentons vient après 4 années de débat
sur les retraites vient après 4 mois de
concertation nous avons fait le choix il
a maintenant quelques mois avec le
président de la République avec la
première ministre de tenir un nouveau
cycle de concertation et nous avons reçu
chacun des partenaires sociaux chacun
des groupes représentés au Parlement
dans les deux chambres que ce soit au
ministère du Travail que ce soit
Matignon à l'occasion de différents
cycles de discussions c'est une
concertation qui a été fructueuse
fructueuse parce que nous avons pu à la
fois et je le dis d'emblée constater un
certain nombre de désaccords mais aussi
nous avons aussi pu des convergences sur
un certain nombre de sujets et je
précise tout aussi rapidement que le
fait de rencontrer ou de construire des
convergences sur tel ou tel sujet sur
tel ou telle mesure concernant ici les
carrières longues la question de la
pénibilité n'importe évidemment pas
l'adhésion à toute la réforme de la part
de celles et ceux avec lesquels nous
avons échangé et discuté ce qui est
important pour moi de souligner c'est
que l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
sans aucune exception à participer à ses
concertations et jusqu'au bout des
concertations que ce soit elle que celle
que nous avons organisé directement au
ministère du Travail ou celle que nous
avons organisée avec la chef du
gouvernement
ces réunions donc permis d'avancer sur
un certain nombre de sujets j'y
reviendrai elles ont aussi permis je
pense notamment aux discussions avec des
forces politiques les groupes
parlementaires d'intégrer dès la
présentation du texte un certain nombre
de d'améliorations qui sont le fruit de
travaux parlementaires ou de demande
parlementaires je pense par exemple à la
réparation d'injustices héritée du passé
que nous rassemblons souvent sous
l'appellation des contratsucs les
travaux d'utilité collective qui
concernent plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont ainsi
travaillé entre le milieu des années 80
et le tout début des années 90 et qui
alors qu'elle demande la liquidation de
leurs droits aujourd'hui constate que
ces périodes n'ont pas été
comptabilisées nous allons les réparer
réparer cette anomalie réparer aussi la
même anomalie pour d'autres types de
contrats qui s'apparentaient à du
travail mais qui n'était pas assujetti à
cotisation faut préciser que la plupart
des contrats aidés sont assujettis à
cotisation permettent de cotiser de
valider des trimestres mais que
certaines formes d'emploi comme les
tubes ne l'était pas
nous avons aussi à l'occasion de cette
discussion améliorées je crois le texte
en prévoyant des la présentation dans le
Parlement la revalorisation du niveau
des pensions les plus basses les plus
faibles pensions pour celles et ceux des
retraités qui ont une carrière complète
et ainsi faire en sorte que cette
garantie de retraite minimale à hauteur
de 85 % du SMIC puisse bénéficier non
seulement aux nouveaux retraités mais
aussi aux actuels retraités nous
estimons qu'il s'agit d'un virgule 8
millions de retraités sur les 17
millions de retraités que nous comptons
aujourd'hui dans le pays qui ainsi
verront cette pension revalorise nous
avons c'est le troisième exemple que je
voulais citer veiller par exemple à
modifier ou à compléter un certain
nombre de dispositions qui concernent
les retraites agricoles la les deux
propositions de loi apportées par André
Chassaigne ont permis de voter pour les
exploitants la garantie d'une retraite
minimum à 85% du SMIC pour une carrière
complète malheureusement un certain
nombre d'indépendants d'exploitants
agricoles doivent cesser leur carrière
de manière un peu anticipée du fait
d'incapacité inaptitude physique due à
la pénibilité du métier et ces carrières
achevées prématurément du fait de cette
incapacité ne sont pas réputés complètes
et c'est ainsi que c'est retraités sont
privés du bénéfice de la retraite
minimum de la loi 5 en élargissant le
champ au retraités qui ont fait valeurs
leurs droits à la retraite pour des
raisons d'inaptitude ou d'incapacité ce
145 000 bénéficiaires nouveau des
garanties châtaignes que nous allons
ainsi permettre d'accompagner nous
aurons aussi à travailler mais je ne
veux pas anticiper sur les travaux du
Sénat des prochains jours sur
l'examen par votre assemblée je crois
que vous l'avez déjà fait en commission
de l'affaire sociale de la proposition
de loi portée par Monsieur Dean
permettant de translater pardon pour
cette Liliane expression le régime des
25 meilleures années que nous
connaissons dans le régime général sur
le régime agricole j'ai la conviction
que nous aurons à l'occasion des débats
à l'Assemblée puis ici même au Sénat la
possibilité d'améliorer encore ce texte
je pense par exemple au droit
d'ouvrir des pensions de réversion aux
enfants en situation de Han qui perdent
leurs parents ouais ça tombe de chantier
je sais que votre assemblée est
particulièrement auquel je sais votre
assembler fait particulièrement
attention j'en viens maintenant à la
réforme telle que nous la présentons et
à ses principales caractéristiques c'est
d'abord une réforme d'équilibre puisque
nous avons un double objectif amélioré
notre système de retraite mais aussi
l'équilibré l'équilibré permet de
répondre à une situation que nous
connaissons qui est celle exposée dans
le cadre du rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites avec un
déficit à la fois structurel et
prolonger mais aussi accrue d'année en
année du système de retraite nous allons
prendre ce rapport du corps et que l'on
le consulte la page 11 était différente
puisque c'est dans cette page 11 il est
précisé que quel que soit la convention
et les scénarios retenus et vous savez
toutes les préventions nous avons pour
une des deux conventions utilisées qui
n'existe pas dans la réalité le système
est là est déficitaire sur les 25
prochaines années et en réalité
lorsqu'on regarde la conventions
d'équilibre par régime le déficit est
beaucoup plus prolongé et beaucoup plus
prononcé dans l'hypothèse centrale
retenu par le rapport il est de 1,8
milliards des 2023 avant de se creuser à
12,5 milliards en 2027 presque 15 en
2030 et d'atteindre 25 milliards d'euros
par an en 2040 c'est cet aspect des
aspects budgétaire finalement qui doit
nous obliger à équilibrer le système
nous sommes absolument convaincus que ne
pas l'équilibrer et finalement d'une
certaine manière le condamner et que
l'attachement que nous avons les uns et
les autres systèmes par répartition doit
nous amener aussi à prendre les
décisions les plus responsables pour que
ce système soit équilibré je crois aussi
que certaines lectures du rapport du
corps sont parfois rapides quand on ne
regarde dans le rapport du corps que
l'évolution des dépenses en pourcentage
de PIB sans tenir compte de l'évolution
des recettes dans le même temps et donc
en inox en ignorant la dégradation du
solde c'est prendre le risque là aussi
de condamner le système par répartition
de fermer les yeux sur le fait tout
simplement qui n'est pas que les
dépenses qui comptent mais les recettes
si un ménage a des dépenses sta mais les
revenus en baisse il va falloir à parier
que le découvert et plus long terme la
faillite le guette et c'est aussi à cela
que nous devons faire attention
nous voulons aussi pouvoir léguer aux
générations qui viennent un système qui
soit équilibré pour pouvoir leur léguer
tout simplement un système de protection
à la retraite sans être étouffé par une
dette ou un semé par des prélèvements
obligatoires il y a un certain nombre
d'options qui peuvent être discutés les
option de diminuer les pensions elle est
inconcevable à nos yeux il y avait
l'option d'augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires elle serait contradictoire
avec tout ce que nous faisons depuis
maintenant un peu plus de 5 ans pour
redonner du souffle à notre
compétitivité au marché du travail au
pouvoir d'achat des Français et donc
nous faisons le choix de l'équilibrer
parce que nous ne voulons pas augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires et nous ne
voulons pas baisser le pouvoir d'achat
des retraités et nous ne voulons pas non
plus dans le même temps laisser la dette
filer sur les 10 prochaines années cela
serait 150 milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires et dans un pays qui est
déjà leur demander était et dans une
période de remontée des taux
obligataires cela nous paraît absolument
inconcevable aussi
aussi pour assurer l'avenir notre
système de retraite nous souhaitons que
nous puissions collectivement travailler
un peu plus longtemps à l'échelle de
chacune de nos vies et ainsi là je
légale sera relevé progressivement comme
vous le savez de trois mois par an à
compter du premier septembre prochain
pour atteindre le 63 ans et 3 mois à la
fin du quinquennat et 64 ans 2030
s'ajoute à cette mesure une accélération
de la mise en oeuvre de la réforme des
Touraine à raison d'un trimestre par an
pour atteindre la durée de cotisation de
43 ans telle qu'elle avait été votée en
2013 à la fin de ce quinquennat
ces mesures finalement ne surprennent
pas véritablement le Sénat puisque elle
rejoignent dans ses modalités un
amendement adopté chaque année par votre
assemblée permettant d'apporter cette
réponse en matière d'équilibre chien à
préciser que nous maintenons à 77 ans
l'âge de suppression de la décote c'est
un point important 77 ans peut paraître
aux yeux de tel ou tel et le débat est
là aussi légitime un âge élevé mais à
chaque fois que l'âge de départ à la
retraite a été relevé l'âge de
suppression de la décote a été relevé en
conséquence et ainsi on le maintenant à
67 ans nous réduisons la période
d'application de la décote et nous
savons que nous protégeons ainsi de la
décote et d'une des cotes aggravée elle
est assurée parfois les plus fragiles et
notamment les femmes puisque beaucoup de
celles et ceux qui vont jusqu'à 67 ans
aujourd'hui pour ne pas être exposé à la
décote sont des femmes du fait de
carrière plus hachées que la moyenne
c'est donc un effort en termes de
travail qui est demandé à tous salariés
indépendant fonctionnaire titulaire de
régime spéciaux pour financer à la fois
le redressement du système et des
mesures de justice et de progrès
l'ensemble de des retraites et des
retraites cet effort va permettre de
dégager des marges de manœuvre à hauteur
d'environ 18 milliards d'euros en 2030
et ces marges de manœuvre seront
utilisées mobilisées pour les deux tiers
afin de permettre le retour à
l'équilibre du système et pour un tiers
pour financer les mesures nouvelles je
disais que ça allait nous permettre de
financer des mesures de justice et de
progrès les mesures de justice sont la
seconde caractéristique que je veux
souligner à l'occasion de la
présentation du texte il s'agit donc de
travailler plus longtemps mais pas pour
tout le monde et pas de la même manière
ainsi c'est le premier point que je veux
souligner nous voulons mieux prendre en
compte les carrières les plus longues
d'abord en conservant un améliorant le
dispositif tel qu'il existe depuis 2003
et en le rendant peut-être plus juste et
plus lisible ainsi lorsque là je l'égale
de départ sera de 64 ans à l'horizon
2030 il restera comme aujourd'hui à 58
ans pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans dans des
conditions facilitées par rapport à
aujourd'hui puisque nous réduirons la
condition de durée d'assurance exigée
il sera à 60 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé entre 16 et 18 ans c'est un
nouveau palier que nous créons et nous
le faisons aussi en cohérence avec la
promotion de l'entrée dans la carrière
professionnelle par l'apprentissage qui
intervient régulièrement entre 16 et 17
ans il sera 62 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à cotiser entre 18
et 20 ans je précise là aussi que le
dispositif permettra de mieux protéger
ou d'être plus ouvert aux femmes en
incluant des périodes de congé parental
dans la prise en compte de la durée
requise pour en bénéficier ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas
des mesures anecdotiques ou marginales
mais bien les améliorations
substantielles pour le seul dispositif
permettant d'intégrer des trimestres de
congés parental cotisés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse pour les parents
de les parents au foyer dans les
trimestres ainsi éligibles il faut avoir
en tête que 1 million 900 000 femmes par
an bénéficient de cette assurance
vieillesse pour les parents au foyer et
que donc parmi elles un nombre assez
considérable vont pouvoir accéder plus
facilement au départ anticipé je précise
aussi pour la transparence et je crois
la sincérité de nos débats que vous ne
trouverez pas dans le pellet FSS rectif
que nous vous présentons de traces de
ces mesures parce qu'elle relève de
nature réglementaire et donc nous les
prendrons par décret par contre dans le
tableau d'équilibre financiers vous
trouverez le coup de ces mesures ce qui
traduit évidemment l'engagement de mise
en œuvre de ces mesures que le
Gouvernement prend devant le Parlement
le deuxième élément de justice concerne
le maintien de départ anticipées pour
les travailleurs les plus fragiles les
victimes d'accidents et de maladies
professionnelles ainsi les personnes
invalides en situation d'inaptitude ou
d'incapacité permanente pourront comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui partir à 62 ans
à taux plein et cela permettra de
maintenir un nombre de départ anticipé
au même niveau qu'aujourd'hui de la même
manière nous voulons faciliter le départ
anticipé des victimes d'accidents du
travail ou de maladies professionnelles
ainsi les victimes d'accidents du
travail ou une maladie professionnelle
et en donner lieu à un taux d'incapacité
supérieure à 20% égale ou supérieur à
20% pour en partir de manière anticipée
de manière automatique sans avis
médicale supplémentaire ce qui n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui et nous faciliterons
aussi les conditions de départ pour ceux
qui sont touchés d'un taux d'invalidité
ou d'incapacité supérieure à 10% et
inférieur à 20%
je précise enfin que les travailleurs en
situation d'handicap continueront à
pouvoir partir à partir de 55 ans il y a
aujourd'hui deux conditions cumulatives
et nous allons faire en sorte qu'il n'y
en ait plus qu'une là aussi pour
faciliter l'accès au départ anticipé
pour les travailleurs handicapés et puis
dernier exemple ou dernier point sur ce
sujet les travailleurs exposés à
l'amiante conservons leur départ à
partir de 50 ans comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui ainsi avec ces mesures sur
les carrières longues comme sur les
travailleurs les plus fragiles et
exposés à des troubles ou en tout cas
une forme d'incapacité inaptitude ou de
handicap nous renforçons les systèmes de
protection et nous facilitons l'accès à
ces systèmes de protection pour bon
nombre de salariés au global et en
réalité de ce que l'on compare l'âge
moyen de départ effectif par rapport à
ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
l'augmentation ne sera pas de deux ans
puisque s'agit là de l'augmentation de
l'âge légal de départ mais en réalité
d'un peu plus de six mois et pour les
retraités qui ont les pensions les plus
les plus faibles les 20% de pension les
plus faibles souvent bénéficiaires à ces
dispositifs puisqu'il y a la moyenne
causalité le décalage sera plutôt de
l'ordre d'un trimestre
toujours en matière de justice il nous
faut donner plus de place et plus
importantes au travail des seniors nous
avons dit c'est à la fois une condition
d'atteindre du plein emploi une
condition de réussite de la réforme il y
a de mesure qui ne relève pas de ce
texte en matière de formation en matière
d'accompagnement de l'emploi des seniors
il y a des mesures qui relèvent très
directement de ce texte notamment pour
faciliter les transitions c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous allons
faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive deux ans avant l'âge de
l'égal de départ et l'ouvrir la fonction
publique nous allons aussi faciliter
l'accès au cumul emploi retraite pour
les retraités qui peuvent qui souhaitent
et parfois qui doivent cumuler un emploi
avec leur retraite nous allons faciliter
cet accès et nous allons faire en sorte
que ce cumulant pour la retraite soit
contributif puisque aujourd'hui un
retraité qui occupe un emploi en
cumulent avec sa retraite cotise pour
l'assurance vieillesse sans que ce soit
créateur de droit et donc nous
autoriserons une seconde liquidation
pour que les cotisations versées au
titre de ce cumul puisse permettre une
revalorisation du niveau des retraites
que soit les régimes de base bien sûr
nous le souhaitons des régimes
complémentaires
nous allons enfin créer un index un
index senior avec
la volonté de l'appliquer à toutes les
entreprises depuis 300 salariés la
volonté de le rendre obligatoire pour
ces entreprises depuis 300 salariés et
ainsi nous prévoyons un dispositif de
sanctions financières sur le modèle de
ce qui se fait pour l'index égalité
professionnelle femme pour les
entreprises qui se soustraient qui
refuseraient cette obligation de
publicité à l'issue des discussions que
nous avons eu avec les partenaires
sociaux organisation d'employeurs et
organisation syndicale ayant considéré
l'index comme un outil intéressant il
est ressorti une fois le résultat a
connu une fois les évolutions connues
plutôt qu'une sanction financière il
était plus utile de prévoir une
obligation de négociation et donc une
obligation de dialogue social obligation
renforcée c'est ce qui nous amène à
intégrer plutôt à réintégrer la question
de l'emploi des seniors aussi des items
de la gestion des emplois des parcours
professionnels donc avec une obligation
de négociation trielle
voilà pour la partie justice j'en viens
un certain nombre de progrès que nous
voulons faire à l'occasion de cette
réforme il s'agit d'abord de mieux
prévenir l'usure professionnelle et nous
entendons améliorer la prise en compte
de la pénibilité nous voulons à la fois
faciliter et renforcer l'accès et les
droits acquis au titre du compte
professionnel de prévention le C2P ce la
place par des ajustements notamment
l'abaissement d'un certain nombre de
critères d'éligibilité nous allons par
exemple à baisser de 120 à 100 nuits le
nombre de nuits travaillées par an pour
obtenir des points nous allons mieux
protéger les travailleurs polyposer nous
allons aussi créer une nouvelle
utilisation de droits des points qui sur
le C2P point qui pourrait être acquis de
manière déplafonnée ce qui est aussi une
nouveauté cette nouvelle utilisation
consiste en un congé pro un congé de
reconversion permettant un salarié
d'arrêter son activité de rester
rémunéré et d'avoir le temps de suivre
une formation qualifiante lui permettant
d'envisager une reconversion et ainsi
une nouvelle orientation qui est
certainement souvent le meilleur moyen
de prévenir la pénibilité les
conséquences de l'usure
nous voulons aussi retravailler sur les
trois critères ergonomiques dans nos
avions constaté en 2017 ils étaient
extrêmement difficiles à mesurer de
manière individuelle en particulier dans
les petites entreprises le porte-charge
lourd des postures pénibles et les
vibrations mécaniques c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous souhaitons à la fois
que les branches professionnelles soient
amenées à négocier les accords de
prévention l'usure professionnelle sur
la base d'une notification par la
branche ATMP des métiers qui sont
considérés comme les plus
potentiellement exposés à la pénibilité
nous savons le faire la branche ATMP le
sait le faire par les taux
d'accidentologie par la prévalence des
maladies professionnelles et en
s'appuyant sur un certain nombre
d'enquêtes comme l'enquête summer qui
permet de déterminer quelles sont ses
métiers les plus exposés pour ces
métiers de l'accord les accords de
prévention ne vont être négociés et
pourront être co-financés par la branche
ATMP à hauteur d'un milliard d'euros sur
le quinquennat ce qui est en rythme
manuel et cinq fois supérieur à ce que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui en matière
de mobilisation de fonds pour la
prévention de la pénibilité
ces métiers font aussi l'objet d'un
suivi médical renforcé articulé autour
de la visite médicale professionnelle
que le Parlement a adopté dans le cadre
de la loi santé au travail à 45 ans
d'une nouvelle visite obligatoire à 61
ans qui a un objectif majeur à mes yeux
qui est de permettre pour ceux qui
malheureusement ont connu et souffre des
conséquences de l'usure professionnelle
d'être sûr de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
départ anticipé avant qu'il soit trop
près de la retraite pour pouvoir
bénéficier pleinement de ce droit je dis
en soulignant que la priorité que je
poursuis qui est celle du gouvernement
et je crois de la plupart des forces
politiques et des partenaires sociaux et
de considérer que 100 000 départs
anticipés pour des questions liées à
l'incapacité l'inaptitude et donc pour
des problèmes physiques
n'est pas un chiffre acceptable et nous
ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire
finalement de la réparation je préfère
mille fois et je crois que nous sommes
nombreux que les salariés puissent aller
jusqu'à l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite dans de bonnes conditions de
santé et ainsi accéder à la retraite en
bonne santé plutôt qu'avoir des salariés
qui bénéficient dans les parenticipés de
2 ans ou 4 ans mais qui débute le
retrait plutôt avec une santé un
organisme abîmé c'est la raison pour
laquelle la prévention est tout à fait
majeure et reste notre priorité nous
allons cependant là aussi faire en sorte
que ce suivi médical renforcé permette
dès les départs anticiper sous l'angle
de la réparation puisque les dispositifs
de prévention aussi efficaces qu'ils
pourraient être ne permettront jamais
malheureusement de concerner tout le
monde et par ailleurs nous savons qu'il
y a un certain nombre de travailleurs
qui travaillent depuis longtemps dans
ses branches et sont d'ores et déjà
exposés à l'usure et pour lesquelles
l'usure a malheureusement fait son œuvre
deuxième progrès que nous voulons
souligner celui qui concerne
l'augmentation de la pension minimale
nous tenons ainsi un engagement pris par
le Président de la République pendant la
campagne présidentielle qui est de
garantir une pension minimale de 85% du
SMIC pour une carrière complètement
cotisée au niveau du SMIC concrètement
nous allons revaloriser le minimum de
pension de 100 euros par mois à partir
du 1er septembre 2023 pour atteindre
près de 1200 euros par mois pour une
carrière complètement cotisée cela
passera par une revalorisation du
minimum contributif majoré et minimum
contributif de base il nous prévoyons
dans le texte une indexation du minimum
de pension elle a liquidation sur le
SMIC pour que cette garantie soit
pérenne et que ce soit une garantie dans
le temps là aussi c'est un effort qu'il
faut souligner puisque on progrès qu'il
faut souligner puisque nous pensons nous
savons même que 200 000 retraités par an
soit un quart des départs à la retraite
bénéficieront d'une revalorisation de
leur pension par rapport à la situation
actuelle et donc bénéficieront par la
réforme d'une pension améliorée et ça
s'applique évidemment au plus petites
pensions
nous allons appliquer je l'ai dit cette
revalorisation pension de retraite
actuelle et cela concerne jusqu'à 1,8
millions de retraités aussi enfin et je
terminerai par là cette réforme est une
réforme d'équité nous considérons
qu'améliorer la solidarité au sein des
générations et est allée c'est une fête
c'est une certaine manière elle est au
bout de la promesse faite par notre
système de répartition de plus d'équité
et c'est pour cela que nous voulons
fermer en matière de retraite un certain
nombre de régimes spéciaux régimes qui
nous paraissent désormais archaïque ou
générateur d'injustices qui ne sont plus
acceptables et nous fermerons donc pour
ce qui concerne la retraite les régimes
spéciaux de la RATP des industries
électriques et gazières des clercs et
des employés de notaire de la Banque de
France et du Conseil économique social
et environnemental nous le ferons en
respectant le contrat social le pacte
social c'est la raison pour laquelle ces
régimes spéciaux de retraite seront
fermés pour les nouveaux embauchés
uniquement à compter du premier
septembre 2023 par contre l'équité
consiste aussi à demander à l'ensemble
des actifs de travailler un peu plus
longtemps c'est aussi pour cette raison
que des entreprises qui salarient des
personnels en régime dans le cadre de
régime spéciaux devront ouvrir très
rapidement des négociations pour mettre
en place des périodes de convergence
comme après la réforme de 2010 et ainsi
relevé l'âge de départ des régimes
spéciaux de 2 ans comme c'est le cas
pour l'ensemble des salariés
enfin l'équité c'est permettre aux
indépendants d'avoir les mêmes droits
que les salariés face au même montant de
prélèvement et c'est pour ça que
parallèlement à l'examen de ce texte
nous engagerons la réforme de l'assiette
sociale pour la concrétiser dans le
cadre du projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 en voyant ce
que les indépendants qui réalisent une
carrière complète bénéficient également
et pleinement de la garantie de retraite
minimale nous avons aussi profité de ce
texte pour solder quelques irritons et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
proposons de stopper définitivement le
processus d'unification du recouvrement
entre l'URSSAF l'agir Carco et la Caisse
des dépôts est consignations voilà
madame la Présidente les principales
caractéristiques du texte je ne doute
pas que sur un certain nombre de public
de questions il y a des interrogations
que les rapporteurs ou les sénatrices et
sénateurs vont relayer j'essaierai d'y
répondre dans les instants qui suivront
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors on va
prendre les questions des trois
rapporteurs qui commencent elizabetho
la justice je dirais social sur laquelle
il repose nous ne sommes pas des
dogmatis seulement nous sommes dans la
réalité
des budgets et en fait
nous sommes devant la réalité
démographique et nous savons que nous ne
pouvons pas maintenir en tout cas ce
système de retraite par répartition sans
avoir un regard sur les finances
publiques et permettre que on puisse
conserver ce modèle qui nous est cher
j'ai plusieurs questions d'abord sur les
effets financiers de la réforme sur la
prévention et la réparation de l'usure
professionnelle et en dernier lieu sur
les cotisations ma première question
concernant les effets financiers de la
réforme et celle-ci vous fondez votre la
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibre du
système de retraite à l'horizon 2030
alors on l'a vu sur une perspective de
déficit du système de retraite de 13,5
milliards d'euros à cette échéance mais
ensuite sur la prévention et la
réparation de l'usure professionnelle
vous avez déjà abordé ce sujet dans vos
propos liminaires mais si vous pouviez
aller un petit peu plus loin vous
prévoyez la création d'un fond
d'investissement dans la prévention de
l'usure professionnelle financée par la
branche ATMP vous avez annoncé qu'il
serait doté d'un milliard d'euros sur le
quinquennat est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser s'il s'agit de dépenses
nouvelles ou si certaines dépenses de
prévention existence sont réorientées
vers le fond et pour quelle raison les
facteurs de pénibilité qui seraient pris
en compte au titre du fond inclut que
les risques ergonomiques comme vous les
avez nommés tout à l'heure générateur de
troubles musculoosquelettiques et non
les agents chimiques dangereux alors que
ces derniers sont également exclus du
compte professionnel de prévention le
C2P
pour terminer sur les cotisations
pourquoi reporter au PLFSS pour 2024 la
refonte de l'assiette sociale des
travailleurs indépendants est-ce que
vous pourriez confirmer que l'ensemble
de ces assurés y compris les non
salariés agricoles seront concernés par
cette réforme voilà ce sont mes
questions je ne doute pas que mes
collègues rapporteurs et notamment René
Paul Savary qui voilà était à l'origine
de de tous ces travaux sur la réforme
des retraites sont à même de poser des
questions complémentaires merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez répondre déjà on prend toutes
les questions des rapporteurs alors René
Paul René Paul
très bien merci merci effectivement
d'avoir rejoint les propositions de la
majorité
sénatoriale mais nous avions un
calendrier un peu plus modéré que ce qui
est proposé aujourd'hui nous permettront
peut-être de le revoir bien entendu nous
souhaiterions également avoir une étude
d'impact
plus importante me semble-t-il qu'il
doit exister que ce que l'on a jusqu'à
présent
si c'était possible puisque nous avons
nous disposons du document de
présentation
et je pense qu'il y a une étude plus
importante d'impact des mesures prises
merci nous les communiquer au plus vite
vous avez déjà répondu à un certain
nombre de questions mais deux trois
précisions comme ça qui nous ont a
priori
sauter aux yeux et qui ne figure pas
forcément directement dans dans le texte
par exemple sur les micros entrepreneurs
puisque certains sont habillés
à
la caisse au régime général et donc vont
par exemple bénéficier des dispositions
du minimum contributif alors que ceux
qui sont reliés restés à la CIPAV
semble-t-il ne bénéficierait pas des
minimum contributifs
c'est peut-être un point à lever
également en ce qui concerne ce minimum
contributif allez-vous faire participer
les régimes complémentaires puisque
c'est un une allocation différentielle
qui prend en compte justement les
pensions des régimes de base et
complémentaires et qu'elle est votre
stratégie dans ce domaine là en ce qui
concerne l'usure professionnelle
il y a la visite médicale qui est tout à
fait intéressante entre 60 61 ans je
pense même qu'elle devrait être
peut-être de façon plus antérieure
qu'elle peut être plus complète qu'une
visite médicale mais c'est très bien
pour ceux qui sont en emploi mais ceux
qui ne sont pas en emploi et on sait
qu'il y en a qui ne sont pas en emploi
quelle mesure avez-vous allez vous
proposer pour effectivement qu'il puisse
bénéficier également de d'une entrevue
médicale ou sociale permettant de
redéfinir la trajectoire de fin d'emploi
de ces personnes là en ce qui concerne
également l'emploi des seniors est-ce
que vous prévoyez une loi travail pour
définir un certain nombre de mesures
parallèlement à ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui qui est une loi plus
budgétaire bien entendu qui prescrit un
certain nombre de dispositifs nous avons
besoin là aussi une vision dans l'avenir
pour voir si nous faisons ou pas un
certain nombre de propositions
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
départs anticipés en retraite
effectivement vous avez mis trois
critères 16 18 20 ans mais pour les
16-18 ans 44 années de cotisation
pour ceux qui sont à compter de la
génération
195 est-ce que ce dispositif peut être
me semble enfin ce dispositif me
semble-t-il peut être éventuellement
modifié puisque il est difficile de
expliquer à ces générations qu'il
travailleront qui sont une durée
d'emploi plus longue que les autres me
semble-t-il et là aussi je pense qu'il y
a des dispositions qui peuvent peut-être
être prises peut-être en avez-vous déjà
envisagé de même vous dites que en ce
qui concerne les carrières actives il
n'est plus nécessaire de finir dans
l'emploi caractérisant la carrière
active pour pouvoir bénéficier de
davantage or il nous semblerait que ça
existe déjà et que celui qui a une
carrière active qui reprend une carrière
qui n'est pas éligible au régime des
actifs puissent bénéficier quand même
des avantages qu'il a eu c'est en tout
cas les réponses que nous font un
certain nombre de caisse et notamment
les centres de gestion également de la
fonction publique territoriale qui nous
disent qu'il n'est pas nécessaire que le
fonctionnaire termine sa carrière sur un
emploi relevant de la caractérise la
catégorie active pour bénéficier du
départ anticipé dans le cadre de ce
dispositif
donc là aussi cela mérite quelques
précisions merci de nous les apporter
merci de m'avoir permis de d'assister à
cette audition et de poser des questions
sur le ministre remercie pour votre
présentation je vais ajouter quelques
questions à celle de mes collègues tout
d'abord pour ce qui concerne l'entrée en
vigueur de la réforme au 1er septembre
j'ai déjà des retours
de la part de certaines catégories ou de
collectivités qui font valoir que une
application aussi rapide une entrée en
vigueur aussi rapide de la réforme
complique parce que les projections des
entreprises ou des collectivités ou je
pense aussi aux enseignants qui ne
peuvent pas partir en cours d'année
compliqué énormément il y a le fait de
pouvoir prendre ses congés lorsqu'on
fait valoir ses droits à la retraite les
comptes épargne temps et le tuilage
entre le remplaçant qui doit reprendre
le poste et le départ du retraité fait
que on
bien souvent et non à l'avance et qu'une
application une entrée en vigueur de la
réforme au 1er septembre 2023 pareil
très très rapide et en tout cas risque
de compliquer le l'organisation et le
coût pour ceux qui se sont déjà
organisés pour remplacer des départs à
la retraite
une interrogation sur les perspectives
et les cotisations dans le prolongement
de des interrogations d'Elisabeth
Doisneau dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur il avait été envisagé de d'avoir une
cotisation vieillesse des plafonnée
est-ce que on a une idée de ce que
pourrait donner une cotisation
vieillesse au-delà du plafond de la
sécurité sociale par exemple jusqu'à 3
passes
concernant la revalorisation des minimas
1200 euros du SMIC brut
est-ce que ça concerne bien les
polypensionnés c'est une une
confirmation que j'aimerais avoir
concernant les régimes spéciaux
sujets qui me tient à coeur
est-ce que vous pourriez nous donner
quelques précisions sur ce qui va
advenir des régimes spéciaux
est-ce que les nouveaux affiliés
rentrant cotisants à la CNAV et agir
Carco est-ce qu'on peut imaginer des
compensations des conventions de
compensation entre
la CNAV et comme ça ça s'est fait
finalement pour la SNCF des
compensations qui permettraient de
rendre une les cotisations des nouveaux
entrants pour pouvoir financer les les
pensions également quel est le devenir
par exemple je pense à la Banque de
France de leur du solde de la caisse ça
représente tout de même un peu plus de
15 milliards pour la Banque de France
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez pour ce le
devenir de cette caisse
ensuite un sujet important qui concerne
la natalité le taux de fécondité est-ce
que vous prévoyez des mesures qui
aillent au-delà de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui en matière de maternité
pour encourager en tout cas
ne pas
dissuader les femmes d'avoir des enfants
je pense qu'on ne peut pas rétablir un
système de retraite par répartition
sans inverser cette courbe décroissante
du nombre d'actifs et en tout cas
soutenir le rythme des générations
voilà de cette de cette manière est-ce
que vous envisagez des des actions
complémentaires et puis
de façon tout à fait liée quel serait le
devenir du Fonds de réserve des
retraites se font de réserve des
retraites à mes yeux devrait être
sanctuarisés tout simplement pour
pouvoir
engranger des excédents quand ce serait
le cas et se prémunir de futur choc
démographique tel que celui qu'on est en
train de connaître
dernier point on est ici au Sénat vous
permettrez d'avoir une attention
que je porte depuis 5 ans avec ma
mission de rapporteur c'est celle de la
retraite des élus et notamment les élus
qui perçoivent des indemnités
inférieures à la moitié du plafond de la
sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire
1833 euros aujourd'hui depuis 2013 les
élus qui perdent plus de la moitié du
plafond de la sécurité sociale cotise à
toutes les cotisations et donc la
cotisation vieillesse la cotisation de
base en cela il conserve des droits à la
retraite plein et entiers et ils peuvent
faire valoir leur carrière pleinement
ceux qui sont en dessous de la moitié du
plafond de la sécurité sociale ne cotise
casser GS et à l'ircantheque retraite
complémentaire mais ne cotise pas à la
retraite de base et je trouve que c'est
une profond d'injustice parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de mères ou
d'adjoint d'élus qui
réduisent leur temps de travail pour
pouvoir exercer cette fonction de maire
ou d'adjoint et en ça perdent des droits
à la retraite puisqu'ils ont une
cotisation de base plus faible et le
pire pour moi c'est que lorsqu'ils font
valoir leur droit à la retraite ils ne
peuvent même pas prétendre à racheter
des trimestres et ça ça me semble
profondément injuste on permettrait un
parallèle
quelqu'un qui a fait de la prison a le
droit de racheter des trimestres pas un
maire dans ce cadre là je trouve que
c'est profondément injuste et j'espère
que ce texte pourra remédier à cette
injustice merci
ce ministre beaucoup de questions
une pause dans les questions
très merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteur peut-être dans l'ordre des
questions telles qu'elles ont été
abordées sur la question des équilibres
financiers et des effets financiers de
la réforme nous prévoyons effectivement
un retour à l'équilibre en 2030 avec une
hypothèse de chômage qui est la 4,5% en
2027 il n'y pesait une hypothèse de
productivité moyenne c'est en cela que
nous qualifions l'hypothèse centrale
vous avez raison de considérer que le
taux de 4,5% de chômage est obligé est
optimiste et c'est l'objet de tous nos
efforts mais il reste optimiste et cela
souligne le besoin de mener les
politiques d'emplois très actifs si le
taux de chômage était moins bas et si la
situation était moins améliorée que nous
l'espérons évidemment ça se traduirait
par des déficits plus importants
au même horizon et une difficulté plus
importante d'atteindre l'objectif assez
horizon nécessitant peut-être de décaler
un peu la date de retour à l'équilibre
mais il nous a semblé cependant
difficile d'aller au et d'anticiper un
scénario plus pessimiste parce que les
mesures te mettant en place doivent
pouvoir l'aide de manière progressive et
anticiper un scénario plus sur un
scénario plus pessimiste nous aurait
conduit à des mesures qu'on qualifie de
paramétrique plus rapide et plus
importantes ce qui aurait été à nos yeux
difficile à mettre en œuvre la
solidarité la solidarité interbranche va
intervenir de la manière suivante nous
constatons et ça fait le lien avec votre
question suivante que la branche ATMP la
caractéristique extrêmement agréable
d'être particulièrement excédentaire à
horizon 2026 nous estimons que
l'excédent sera 3,3 milliards d'euros
une fois retraité les virements outils
de la solidarité interbranche qui sont
traditionnellement adoptées en PLFSS
autour d'un milliard un milliard centres
des sous-déclarations pour les accidents
du travail et donc après ce retraitement
il reste 3,3 milliards d'euros
si nous nous considérons que la
mobilisation de nouveaux moyens pour le
fond de prévention l'usure
professionnelle mobilise 200 millions
d'euros sur 3,3 milliards d'euros il
reste 3 milliards 100 par définition et
si nous diminuons la cotisation ATMP
versée par les employeurs pour environ
un milliard d'euros cela permet de
garder un excédent autour de 2 milliards
ce qui est sur une caisse de caisse à
une branche ATMP gérant 17 milliards par
an un excédent qui reste tout à fait
raisonnable et même confortable et cette
diminution de la cotisation ATMP a
autant d'un milliard d'euros serait
compensé par une augmentation de la
cotisation CNAV des employeurs de 0,12
points représentant un milliards d'euros
aussi c'est neutre pour l'employeur
c'est notre pour les employeurs mais ça
permet par contre
de générer un milliard d'euros de
recettes au titre de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse et ainsi dans les
bornes du système de retraite de
participer à l'équilibre et à cette
atteinte d'objectif d'équilibre les
risques
ergonomiques sont la priorité des
accords de prévention d'usure
professionnelle mais bien évidemment
nous serons ouverts dans le cadre des
négociations pour voir quels sont les
autres risques qui pourraient être ainsi
prévenus je fais juste une parenthèse
pour dire que l'exposition des agents
chimiques est évidemment un point qu'il
ne faut pas sous-estimer nous
considérons mais je suis tout à fait
ouvert évidemment au débat sur ce point
là que sur les questions d'agents
chimiques la question doit pas être
réglée en termes de prévention sur site
de travail ou de réparation mais doivent
vont être réglés par des normes
d'interdiction et pour empêcher cette
exposition c'est la raison pour laquelle
pour nous cela arrive plus de la
sécurité que de la pénibilité et c'est
la raison aussi pour laquelle nous
n'avons pas réintégré de la même manière
ce risque lié à l'exposition au risque
chimiques Monique le bain merci madame
la Présidente bon moi je ne
m'étonnerai pas sur certains membres de
choses que j'ai envie de dire nous
aurons quelques jours de débat et donc
nous aurons l'occasion de dire ce que
nous avons envie de dire
j'ai quelques questions pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas fait un véritable projet
de loi sur les retraites parce que
toutes les mesures d'accompagnement que
dont vous nous parlez soit vous nous
dites qu'elles seront prises par décret
et décré on sait ce qu'il en est soit
ils ne sont jamais pris soit ils nous
réserve certaines surprises comme la
surprise qu'on a eu le 23 décembre avec
le décret qui finalement n'a pas été
pris sur l'indemnisation des chômeurs
ou alors vous nous dites que il y aura
une mesure une projet de loi oui ça vous
fait beaucoup rire excusez-moi
pas ça pourtant très rigolo et donc
soit il y aura un projet de loi
supplémentaire bon enfin voilà
alors en fait vous pose la question mais
je sais bien pourquoi vous n'avez pas
fait un projet de loi retraite et
pourquoi vous êtes passé par une loi de
finance rectificative pour des raisons
uniquement de politique politicienne
mais c'est bien dommage quand même parce
que les salariés les futurs retraités
méritaient mieux que ça sur les
questions pratiques
le fait de reculer l'âge à 64 ans va
susciter quelques économies en termes de
surcote puisqu'on a des salariés qui
auraient pu bénéficier du surcote et qui
n'en n'auront plus est-ce que vous
envisagez du coup
d'améliorer le système de décote et
notamment pourquoi pas pour les femmes
sur l'apprentissage la loi Touraine
avait permis a permis aux
apprentis enfin à ceux qui ont été
apprentis de de faire en sorte que leur
que trimestre d'apprentissage compte
pour la retraite mais c'est depuis 2014
est-ce que on peut envisager
de prendre en compte les trimestres
d'apprentissage
pour les années antérieures
vous avez parlé des tucs je sais que
vous avez il y a une mission à
l'Assemblée nationale et je fais partie
des gens qui qui ont été saisis comme
d'autres sur les tuques vous allez les
prendre en fin vous allez leur donner
des droits à retraite ce qui est bien
dans quelles conditions
les bonifications pour enfants
les femmes aujourd'hui bénéficient de 8
trimestres par enfant
ça les aide pour un certain pour un
grand nombre d'entre elles à avoir les
carrières à taux plein à pouvoir partir
à la retraite à l'âge légal avec des
carrières à taux plein pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles du coup qui devront
travailler un peu plus finalement c'est
bonification pour enfants c'est
trimestre supplémentaire nous trouverons
plus leur utilité donc que restera-t-il
finalement pour pour les femmes qui qui
comment dire qui avait comme
bon alors je sais pas comment il faut
appeler ça qu'on pense à Sion
ces trimestres pour finalement les les
mois qu'elles avaient passé
à s'occuper de leurs enfants est-ce
qu'on peut envisager donc une autre
forme pour pour les femmes une autre
forme de
soutien comme ça a été dit d'ailleurs à
la maternité
et enfin moi j'avoue aussi que je ne
comprends pas bien j'ai besoin d'une
explication technique sur les 1200 euros
parce que moi j'avais cru comprendre que
c'était donc une augmentation à 85% du
SMIC
de la retraite donc retraite principale
plus retraite complémentaire donc avec
un appel aux caisses de retraite
complémentaire et maintenant j'entends
parler de minimum contributifs j'avoue
que je comprends pas là j'ai besoin
d'une vraiment techniquement d'une
explication merci
si Mélanie fauchel merci Madame en
présidente monsieur le ministre je crois
que ma question va va bien avec la
dernière question de ma collègue parce
que ma première question est exactement
sur cette affaire de des 1200 euros le
gouvernement a beaucoup communiqué sur
le fait que dans cette réforme il y
avait un équilibre éco au fond des
sacrifices étaient nécessaires pour
rétablir le niveau des petites retraites
notamment autour de cet exemple phare
d'une personne fictive je crois dans mes
souvenirs qu'elle s'appelait Hélène mais
je crois qu'elle n'existe pas qui
pouvait bénéficier
qui pouvait bénéficier d'une hausse à
hauteur donc de 85% du SMIC soit 1200
euros après avoir cotisé toute sa vie au
SMIC avec une carrière complète bon déjà
de ce que je comprends c'est pas 1200
mais 1193 je sais que pour certains 7
euros c'est pas grand chose voire rien
mais pour d'autres personnes c'est
beaucoup
précision mis de côté sur les 7 euros
depuis ce que j'ai compris c'est qu'en
réalité c'est pas exactement la réalité
et que beaucoup de personnes qui
seraient touchées par cette hausse du
minimum contributif n'arriverait pas à
la fin avec une avec une pension qui
serait à hauteur de 1200 euros donc moi
je voudrais savoir quelque chose de très
simple est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
non pas combien de personnes vont être
touchées par le dispositif non pas de
combien de personnes vont voir le
minimum contributif réhausser mais
combien de personnes touchées par le
dispositif vont se retrouver à la fin
cette réforme avec une retraite à
hauteur de 1200 euros je pense que c'est
un chiffre assez simple qui est
important à connaître puisque c'est
présenté comme étant une des mesures
positives de cette réforme et ce serait
important de savoir combien de personnes
vont être touchées la deuxième question
c'était sur un sujet qui a beaucoup qui
a beaucoup occupé nos débats ces
derniers jours sur l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes puisque de l'étude
d'impact que le ministère lui-même
publié il apparaît que les femmes vont
être davantage touchées que les hommes
en moyenne par la durée l'augmentation
de la durée du temps de travail et
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit que
ceux-ci ne creusait pas les inégalités
entre les femmes et les hommes puisque
et même que ça rétablissait un certain
nombre de choses sous-entendu
aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt les femmes
qui sont avantagées puisqu'elles doivent
travailler un peu moins que les hommes
et donc là elle va devoir travailler un
peu plus et ça rétablirait un peu
sachant que en moyenne en France les
femmes touchent une retraite environ 40%
inférieurs à celle des hommes est-ce que
vous considérez que aujourd'hui
les femmes ont un avantage indu en ce
qui concerne leur temps de travail et
les retraites et enfin je voulais juste
rebondir sur la question de l'exposition
aux substances chimiques vous avez dit
moi je partage je préfère aussi que en
fait personne soit exposée à des
substances chimiques dangereuses plutôt
que d'avoir des personnes qui sont en
mauvaise santé et qu'on doit faire
partir plus tôt parce qu'elles sont
mauvaises santé je préfère que tout le
monde soit une bonne santé je voulais
donc savoir si le gouvernement avait
prévu des améliorations prochaines pour
éviter l'exposition aux substances
chimiques dangereuses des salariés afin
que nous n'ayons plus besoin d'avoir ce
critère je vous remercie
Corinne Ferret merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre à mon
tour de vous interroger pour ce moment
de d'audition sur des des points très
concrets viendra le temps du débat et
croyez moi on aura beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à dire sur cette réforme qui est
injuste qui est brutal et qui n'est pas
utile cela dit je voulais vous
interroger sur la pénibilité
vous avez il a été décidé en tout cas
dans cette réforme que les cotisations
vieillesse employeur serait augmenté et
qu'elle serait cette augmentation serait
compenser par une baisse du taux de
cotisation sur la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle la
première ministre ayant dit vous le
venez de le répéter que l'excédent de
cette branche était très important voire
très fort et qu'on pouvait ainsi agir
je rappelle
au préalable que cette branche est
constituée en tout cas les recettes de
cette branche sont constituées de 97% de
cotisations des entreprises comme son
nom l'indique accident du travail
maladie professionnelle ça se
contracte tout ça se passe en entreprise
et ce n'est évidemment pas du fait du
salarié alors l'excédent vous avez
annoncé quelques chiffres moi je veux
aussi insister sur une partie on en
parle à chaque examen du PLFSS sur le
volet sous déclaration on l'appelle
comme ça on constate que de nombreuses
déclarations
d'accidents du travail ne sont pas
faites ou réaliser en entreprise et pour
le coup elle bascule ou elles sont elles
relèvent à ce moment-là de la branche
maladie je dis cette c'est sous
déclarations sont très fortes puisque on
considère là pour aujourd'hui on va dire
cette année passée donc on est de
l'ordre de 1 million deux à un milliard
deux à deux milliards d'euros donc pour
cela la branche ATMP reverse à la
branche maladie chaque année un certain
montant mais le gouvernement depuis
quelques années considère que il faut se
baser sur la fourchette basse et non pas
sur le fourchette hausse j'ai souvenir
dans nos débats de PLFSS que nous
disions que ça ne devait pas procéder
ainsi mais vraiment sur la fourchette
hausse haute et non pas comme cela est
proposé aujourd'hui donc cet excédent
moi je le minerai
y compris au regard des chiffres que
vous avez que vous avez de vous avez
indiqué et quand on parle d'excédent
dans nos débats
annuels sur le pfss et bien fort de ce
constat on va dire nous avons demandé
mais pas seulement notre groupe à la
fois que
puisque excédant il n'y a il y a
beaucoup plus de crédit consacré à la
prévention des risques des risques
professionnels refusé qu'il n'y ait une
augmentation aussi des budgets consacrés
dédiés à la nacte l'agence nationale
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
parce que quand même pas rien et elle a
un rôle important qu'il n'y ait aussi
une augmentation des crédits ou des
financements pour les différents fonds
dédiés aux victimes que ce soit les
victimes de l'amiante les victimes du
chlore déconne et je me souviens en 2020
que nous avions déposé et discuter
débattus une proposition de moi pour la
création d'un fond covid qui bien
évidemment n'avait pas reçu le soutien
du gouvernement j'ai bien évidemment
parce que voilà les choses sont ainsi
donc voilà
comment cet excédent aussi pourrait être
utilisé je sais pas si c'est le terme
qui convient mais il n'y a véritablement
matière à
attribuer cet excédent à des besoins qui
sont réels alors vous dites que au
travers de cette réforme le gouvernement
se propose de faire plus encore voir
mieux sur la pénibilité mais je vais
vous rappeler ma cruauté de vous
rappeler qu'en 2017 le gouvernement de
Monsieur Macron
s'est précipité on va dire pour retirer
quatre critères sur les 10 du compte
pénibilité et pas des moindres pas de
charge lourdes d'exposition au
vibrations donc voilà de très nombreux
salariés sont confrontés à ces assez
difficultés de travail alors est-ce que
demain ou est-ce que dans cette réforme
que vous proposez parce que les choses
sont assez floues sur la pénibilité
est-ce que les cas tous ces quatre
critères essentiels seront réintégrés
pour que tous les salariés qui sont
encore une fois qu'ils doivent y faire
face puisse
le valoriser on va dire au regard du
programme que vous proposez enfin
il est proposé aussi la création d'un
fond d'un milliard d'euros pendant le
mandat pour
souscrire ou accompagné
on va dire ce soutien à la prise en
charge ou à la prise en compte ou à
l'évolution la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
moi je quelques inquiétudes ou
interrogations on va dire au regard de
ce que j'ai précisé depuis tout à
l'heure
un excédent qui n'est pas à mon sens au
niveau que vous évoquiez une un
transfert sur la branche
maladie qui n'est pas au niveau
tel qu'il est il devrait être
qui est minorée là aussi même si à terme
se transfert ne devrait quasiment plus
exister c'est à dire que là aussi il y a
des actions d'information de
sensibilisation pour que toutes ces
déclarations relèvent bien de la branche
ATMP soit bien faite dans le cadre de
l'accident du travail maladie
professionnelle et non pas dans le cadre
d'un de la branche maladie voilà donc
mes questions mes interrogations pour ce
premier temps d'échange merci vraiment
de penser et Annick jacquemais et on en
aura terminé avec les questions vraiment
de conséquences oui merci Madame ma
présidente monsieur le ministre alors
écoutez vous entendre j'avais prévu des
questions mais je vais en faire d'autres
parce que je vous ai écouté
attentivement et j'ai remarqué tout
comme je l'ai fait remarquer ce matin
lors de du rapport sur le duo conseil
des finances publiques que vous avez un
point aveugle qui est assez intéressant
c'est à dire que vous dites la réforme
va rapporter 18 milliards deux tiers on
retrouve les 12 milliards de déficits
sont affectés au rétablissement des
comptes de du des retraites et puis bon
prince vous un tiers ira à
l'amélioration toutes ces améliorations
dont je vous ai parlé et qui sont
souvent
tout simplement l'atténuation de la
brutalité de la réforme
mais il y a un point aveugle là qui
avez-vous fait des 3,9 milliards que
dont parle le corps qui dit que votre
retraite enfin induites par votre
réforme et notamment l'ouverture deux
ans après des droits de la retraite va
entraîner des dépenses de certaines
prestations à hauteur donc de 3,9
milliards ils sont où là dans votre
calcul je les vois plus j'ai pas eu la
réponse ce matin peut-être allez-vous me
la donner parce que je pense que le
tiers d'amélioration c'est aussi
c'est pas tout à fait de l'amélioration
ça doit être de pouvoir compenser
d'ailleurs on parle souvent d'un tiers
pour ces dépenses induites dans d'autres
branches effectivement que ce soit le
RSA pour les collectivités territoriales
ou que ça soit le chômage enfin ce qu'il
en reste puisque vous le réduisez
de réforme en réforme et
donc j'aimerais que vous me redonniez
alors pourquoi je dis ça parce que
effectivement 3,9 milliards c'est tout à
fait plausible pourquoi parce que vous
madame la rapporteur a dit votre votre
réforme est rapide moi je dirais qu'elle
est brutale parce qu'en fin de compte
sur qui va peser vont peser ces
économies elles vont peser sur la
tranche d'âge 55 61 ans ceux qui
devaient partir vous savez ça commence
c'est cette année et alors qui sont ces
55 61 ans comment sont-ils aujourd'hui
vous savez très bien qui sont
pour un quart un fin pour une petite
moitié encore un emploi mais que
effectivement un quart n'est ni en
emploi ni en retraite
cela vous sont-ils bien ils sont au RSA
ils sont en inactivité
où ils sont au chômage bien chômage il y
en a 10% qui sont au chômage dans ce que
je viens de dire et cela vos promesses
sur l'amélioration de la pénibilité sur
tout ce que vous allez faire pour les
seniors afin que le taux d'emploi soit
supérieur vous vous conviendrez que
c'est pas ceux qui ont 59 60 ans qui
sont 20% ni en emploi
en retraite sur lequel ces fameuses
promesses que vous nous faites vont
s'appliquer donc cela vous le savez
c'est ces années enfin c'est trimestres
et ces années de prolongation c'est
l'allongement pour autant et a dû auteur
je dirais du sas de précarité où ils
sont d'autant plus le chômage a été
réduit de plusieurs mois vous savez que
cela ils ont un taux de retour à
l'emploi qui est catastrophique qui de
l'ordre de 30% et que ils font le gros
en gros ils sont du chômage de longue
durée parce qu'en fin de compte il
retrouve pas un emploi bien alors où
sont ces quatre milliards de qui en
quelque sorte consomme une partie du
bénéfice du bénéfice il y en a de la
retraite et d'ailleurs je note que 1/3
d'amélioration ce que vous dites le
fameux tiers
je vois que c'est les travailleurs quand
même qui se payent l'amélioration de
leur système il y a un partenaire là il
y a un acteur qui a disparu c'est
l'employeur quoi je croyais que la
retraite c'était du côté employeur du
côté salarié là c'est les salariés qui
bossent beaucoup plus pour se payer le
peu d'amélioration que vous avez
consenti
alors
par rapport à ça il y a un petit point
technique aussi que j'aimerais c'est par
rapport à ce qui a été dit sur
la cotisation ATMP qui passe
effectivement pour partir à la
vieillesse moi j'aimerais bien savoir si
c'est neutre pour l'employeur notamment
parce que je crois savoir quand même que
les cotisations vieillesse font l'objet
de large exonération patronales et
social et donc ils vont en bénéficier
pour 1,6 du SMIC etc alors que la TMP ne
bénéficiait d'aucune exonération donc je
moi je j'ai déjà posé la question m'a
pas répondu mais là maintenant j'ai le
ministre donc je pense que lui il sait
si c'est vraiment neutre ou si
effectivement par le biais des
exonérations d'un côté bon voilà
une dernière chose que je dirais c'est
que bon que vous soyez que nous nous
fassiez pour ne jamais solliciter
l'employeur c'est vrai que les
dividendes sont au plus bas les profits
aussi les profils du CAC 40 tout ça
c'est au plus bas il faut rétablir
effectivement ça le partage des
richesses et très et très satisfaisant
il s'est dégradé maintenant il
déstabilisait un niveau dégradé donc
vous parlez souvent de compétitivité bon
moi je ne crois pas trop en tant que
économiste assez à cet argument je pense
que c'est vraiment la profitabilité que
vous préservez là mais vous parlez
souvent quand même du pour ne pas
augmenter les cotisations du pouvoir
d'achat alors moi j'aimerais vous dire
que autant vous pouvez parler du côté de
la compétitivité au nom des employeurs
que vous entendez très bien et dont vous
avez une oreille quand même bien
complaisante autant moi je vous demande
d'arrêter de parler au nom des salariés
parce que effectivement si vous leur
demandez si vous voulez
derrière regardez les enquêtes quand
même que et y compris des enquêtes de
cabinets très libéraux
59% des Français seraient d'accord pour
une augmentation des cotisations pour
éviter votre réforme brutale
d'allongement du temps de travail selon
le baromètre de l'adresse 2021 plus de
trois personnes interrogées sur quatre
se disent opposés à la baisse des
prélèvements obligatoires quand de fait
elles sont associées à une baisse des
droits sociaux et c'est ce que vous avez
fait l'année dernière avec la loi du
pouvoir d'achat vous dites voir vous
vous payez pas de cotisations regardez
là sans désocialiser etc et tout mais
vous leur avez pas dit
quand ils ont 6000 jusqu'à 6000 de
primes des socialisés que
ils alimentent plus la caisse de
vieillesse et que il faudra quand même
qu'il travaille un peu plus longtemps et
si vous leur aviez dit ça je pense que
il serait un peu moins intéressé par ça
voilà donc
moi je pense que il faut que vous
regardiez vraiment les sondages car les
Français dans leur grande majorité de
toute façon ne veulent plus qu'on
arbitre si vous voulez les gains de
productivité en faveur des du pouvoir
d'achat ils veulent enfin pour la partie
qui je parle pas bien sûr des des de la
partie la plus défavorisée ils veulent
pouvoir arbitrer les gains de
productivité en faveur aussi de leur
temps libre en faveur d'une meilleure
articulation de leur temps de travailler
en tant que écologiste je vous dirais
que si on pouvait arrêter
de produire
pour terminer monsieur le ministre vous
pourrez oui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour vos
explications déjà moi j'ai été beaucoup
interpellée sur les règles qui régissent
la réversion des pensions de retraite et
la différence qu'il y a entre le secteur
privé et le secteur public alors dans le
secteur privé les salariés bénéficient
d'un taux de réversion qui est plus
avantageux
la pension de réversion du régime
général est égal à 54% de la pension de
l'assuré décédée 60% dans la plupart des
régimes complémentaires du privé contre
50% dans le secteur public par contre si
le défunt exerce une activité ou exercer
une activité dans le secteur privé les
pensions de réversion des époux
survivants sont soumis à des conditions
d'âge et de ressources qui n'existent
pas pour les fonctionnaires
d'une part concernant la condition de
ressources le conjoint survivant ne peut
pas prétendre recevoir de pensions de
réversion si c'est revenu annuels sont
supérieurs à
2341,61 euros brut pour une personne
seule et
375006,56 € brut pour une personne
vivant en couple et d'autre part
concernant la condition d'âge le
conjoint survivant sera privé de
l'intégralité de sa pension de réversion
si la moins de 55 ans alors pour
beaucoup de personnes que j'ai
rencontrées elles ont un grand sentiment
d'injustice donc je voulais vous
demander c'est quelque chose était prévu
un assouplissement une modification de
ses règles dans le dans le cadre des
textes qu'on va étudier et sinon est-ce
qu'on pourrait pas au moins modifier
l'effet de seuil dans le secteur
on envisageant pour plutôt un
pourcentage qu'un plafond de ressources
voilà merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
beaucoup de questions
merci Madame il y a quelques questions
que je vais essayer d'aborder d'abord
monsieur
de la réforme il revient pas je voudrais
simplement préciser que pour ce qui
concerne la pension minimum à l'issue
d'une carrière complète cotisée au
niveau du SMIC nous sommes bien et
j'entends la difficulté d'explication
mais nous sommes bien sur près 2200
euros bruts ce qui correspond à 85 % du
SMIC net à la fin de l'année 2023 une
fois qu'on a déterminé ce niveau de
pension brut en disant près de 1200
euros brut et cela dépendra en réalité
du montant exact du SMIC fin 2023 comme
cela dépendra du montant exact fin 2024
et ensuite année après année les seuls
prélèvements qui s'appliquent sur cette
pension consiste en la CSG et avec une
seconde précision à apporter qui tient
en fait que nous ne pouvons pas indiquer
individu par individu lorsque nous
sommes interrogés le pourcentage CSG qui
est appliqué puisqu'entre le toit zéro
le taux à 3,8 et le taux majoré cette
détermination du taux ne dépend pas
d'une guimau de la retraite mais du
niveau de ressource du foyer fiscal à
laquelle appartient à l'assuré nous
pouvons préjugés mais il y aura toujours
une exception nous pouvons préjugé que
les titulaires d'une pension minimum
telle qu'un si calculée à partir de rond
plutôt généralement à des foyers un
sujet Tito à zéro ou auto à 3,8 mais il
peut toujours y avoir une exception et
on peut très bien imaginer qu'un assuré
soit bénéficiaire de la retraite minimum
tout en partageant sa vie avec un autre
assuré gagnant beaucoup plus d'argent et
amenant un assujettissement au taux
majoré sur la question de la durée de
cotisation je crois avoir répondu assez
largement à la question de Monsieur
vanderenberg tout à l'heure en répondant
aux trois rapporteurs sur le fait que
nous sommes dans une logique de
rapprochement au maximum des durées de
cotisations effectives de chacun des
assurés pour faire en sorte que cette
durée minimum de cotisations exigée par
nos textes ne soient pas exagérément
dépassé pour avoir accès une retraite à
taux plein la mesure qui consisterait à
dire supplément tel ou telle condition
c'est d'être très rapidement à plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros mais nous
aurons l'occasion d'y revenir dans le
débat il y a un lien
que vous avez souhaité ou en tout cas
sur lequel vous m'avez interrogé entre
la prise en compte nouvelle des trois
critères ergonomiques à la fois par la
mise en œuvre d'accords de prévention
branche par branche puisque ce sont les
branches qui est des citrons qui est
discuteront les décideront et le suivi
médical permettant des départs anticipés
le dispositif que nous proposons pour
les trois critères à ergonomiques et
vraiment articulé autour de cela de la
prévention et un suivi médical pour un
départ anticipé sur avis médical si nous
faisions un lien comme monsieur le
sénateur le suggère entre ces trois
critères ergonomiques et le C2P cela
était dit dans d'autres interventions je
crois madame ferry ou madame l'humain
pardonnez-moi si je fais une confusion
cela consisterait à dire que
l'exposition à ces trois critères
ergonomiques serait pourvoyeuse de
points acquise au titre du C2P et avec
ces points qui Audi du CDP on peut
obtenir des départs anticipés de droits
sans avis médical
or et c'est là pour dire les choses très
clairement un point désaccord que nous
n'avons pas su résoudre avec les
organisations syndicales réformistes en
particulier nous considérons que le
dispositif que nous proposons permet des
départs anticipés donc une forme de
réparation comme l'utilisation des
points C2P en tenant compte de
l'effectivité de l'exposition à ces
trois critères ergonomiques je prends un
exemple pour illustrer le propos
l'expliquer lorsque nous travaillons sur
des métiers que nous considérons comme
très probablement exposés à cette
pénibilité liée aux trois critères
ergonomiques il y a fort à parier que le
métier de menuisier soit exposé parce
que si vous êtes menuisier sur une
charpente dans des chantiers extérieurs
exposés au froid au chaud et à la
manipulation directe évidemment que le
port de charge les vibrations les
postures pénibles sont au rendez-vous de
ce métier-là est nécessite une
réparation en tant que nécessaire par
contre si vous êtes menuisier dans un
atelier avec parfois
une température contrôlée et en
utilisant une machine à commande
numérique l'exposition à la pénibilité
aux trois critères est très différente
et pourtant vous avez le même métier
d'un point de vue administratif et donc
le suivi médical renforcer individuel
permet de tenir compte de l'effectivité
le second exemple qui est souvent évoqué
même si ça reste un métier pénible dans
les deux cas à mes yeux concerne les
aides-soignante dans un EHPAD ou tous
les lits sont équipés de rails de leves
malade n'expose pas la même pénibilité
qu'être exfolant dans un EHPAD qui ne se
pose pas ses équipements et donc le
suivi médical permet aussi d'apporter
cette réponse différencie en fonction de
l'effectivité des conditions de travail
sur la question des seniors et de
l'intégration des recettes liées aux
emplois créés je vous confirme monsieur
le sénateur c'est bien intégré dans la
maquette financière les 300 000 que vous
avez évoqués sous la forme de
d'amélioration du niveau des recettes de
la CNAV enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur
deux choses la clause de revoyure est
les risques liés à l'article 40 pour ce
qui concerne la clause de revoyure je
pense que
nous devons responsabilités pour ce
qu'on sert le gouvernement et le
Parlement jugera adopter une trajectoire
de relèvement de l'âge qui permet
d'assurer l'équilibre à horizon 2030
après une fois que j'ai dit cela si le
Parlement et c'est son droit le plus
strict il n'est même pas de question
David gouvernemental à la matière c'est
le Parlement souhaite mettre en place
des modalités haddocks de suivi de la
mise en œuvre et les effets de la mise
en œuvre de la loi j'y seraient tout à
fait ouvert et le gouvernement y
apportera son concours j'ai notamment en
tête ce qui a été mis en place pour le
suivi des effets et la mise en oeuvre du
plan de relance avec un comité addock
permettant d'éclairer les travaux et
d'avoir
un regard à la fois parlementaire et
extérieur sur les effets de ce plan de
relance sur l'article 40
la recevabilité au titre ou lire ce
habitat au titre de l'article 40 au-delà
du fait qu'elle n'appartient pas au
gouvernement bien évidemment ne dépend
pas de la nature du texte on prend pas
les fesses rectificatif ou un projet de
loi doc mais bien de la nature des
dépenses qui seraient proposées de leur
éligibilité vous me demandez de faire
preuve d'ouverture d'esprit ce n'est pas
une caractérise le plus mais
il y a un certain nombre de dispositions
qui évidemment
nécessiteront de faire preuve de cette
ouverture j'ai dit monsieur le sénateur
et je prends ce simple exemple à
l'occasion de réponse en commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale et hier lors des séances de
questions au Gouvernement devant la même
assemblée nationale que nous étions très
ouverts à des systèmes qui permettent de
faciliter le rachat de trimestre pour
études longues ou pour les stages en
période de formation et si je les dis
c'était aussi pour que cette déclaration
publique que j'ai faite au nom du
gouvernement permette par anticipation
de lever les recevabilité au titre de
l'article 40 c'est la démonstration nous
savons faire quand nous le souhaitons
pour permettre de donner un peu de marge
de Man
au parlementaire c'est un début sur le
rapporteur c'est un début
madame Duba enfin m'a interrogé pardon
après et ensuite m'a interrogé sur la
nature du texte si nous avons retenu le
choix d'un pdfss rectif c'est parce que
l'ensemble des dispositions la
quasi-totalité des dispositions pardon
nous présentons des impacts en termes de
coûts ou de recettes pour les comptes
sociaux et ainsi nous a paru plus
logique de le faire comme cela la décote
que vous dont vous appelez l'aménagement
et finalement déjà aménager d'une
certaine manière par les dispositions
que nous proposons le fait de maintenir
là je suppression la décote à 67 ans
soit 3 ans après le nouvel âge
d'ouverture des droits c'est une
première dans la mesure où chaque
relèvement de l'âge de départ c'était
accompagné d'un relèvement de l'âge de
suppression de la décote et ainsi avec
ce que nous proposons la décote qui
aujourd'hui peut atteindre 25% et limité
à 15 c'est un premier aménagement je
peux entendre que ça ne voit soit pas
suffisant à vos yeux mais je tenais à le
souligner parce que c'est aussi une
protection pour éviter d'aller trop loin
en termes d'âge pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont pas une carrière complète
sur la question des trimestres
d'apprentissage je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir mais je vois deux
questions derrière votre intervention la
première c'est si j'ai bien compris
est-ce que les trimestres
d'apprentissage réalisés avant 2014 et
le relèvement des rémunérations
permettant de fait d'être dans un niveau
de l'amélioration validant un trimestre
pourrait être pris en compte en fait il
y a deux possibilités soit les apprentis
en question par le nombre d'heures sur
lequel ils ont payé des cotisations et
le niveau de rémunération on cotisait à
hauteur de 150 heures par trimestre au
niveau du SMIC de l'époque et ça
nécessite de reconstituer les carrières
il y a une seconde possibilité qui est
moins
qui est moins positive enfin je ne sais
pas si je vais le dire comme ça mais qui
est moins attrayante qui est d'autoriser
de faciliter le rachat de trimestre
réalisé au titre de l'apprentissage
lorsque ceux-ci n'ont pas donné lieu à
cotisation ou sur des niveaux de
cotisations très bas ça fait partie des
choses que l'on peut aussi regarder pour
faciliter notamment dans le cas
d'apprentis qui dans certaines
situations il a fort longtemps
maintenant pouvait être rémunérés sur
des montants de rémunération très très
bas très très ou très très basse mais en
tout cas c'est quelque chose que l'on
peut regarder en fonction des périodes
et des reconstitutions de carrière sur
la bonification pour
enfants et le fait qu'aujourd'hui il
trimestres général alors que ces deux
dans le régime public je suis très
ouvert je l'ai dit cet après-midi parce
qu'il y a une réflexion sur les droits
familiaux de manière générale est-ce que
je dis là est vrai pour les pensions de
reversion ça renvoie à votre
intervention je crois madame pensez bon
je madame non pardon madame Jacques mais
pardonnez-moi parce que il y a trop de
différence sur les seules pensions de
reversion il y a 13 régimes qu'il y a un
cadre des pensions de réversion et
derrière ce nombre de régime il y a
autant d'injustices et d'inégalités et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous en
avons saisi le corps mais c'est aussi je
pense un sujet que nous aurons beaucoup
de profits à regarder ensemble sur la
base initiative et de travaux
parlementaires
sur la question du niveau minimum de
pension comme j'ai dit à Monsieur Savary
tout à l'heure ça n'est pas une
allocation ou une garantie
différentielle tout régime c'est le
relèvement du minimum contributif et
donc ce que nous proposons
d'accord mais il n'y a pas de souci mais
comme par ailleurs madame l'Huma m'avait
aussi interrogé je réponds tout aussi
directement sur le minimum de pension
c'est un relèvement du minimum
contributif et nous ont le choix de le
relever de 75 euros le minimum
contributif majoré qui est accessible
pour tout assurer ayant ayant cotisé 120
trimestres à l'échelle de sa carrière
c'est à dire 30 ans et de 25 euros du
minimum contributif de base c'est un mix
pardon pour la mauvaise expression qui
permet de couvrir le plus de monde
possible et ça permet notamment de
couvrir les carrières hachées puisque ça
permet l'accès à tout tout partie de
cette revalorisation pour des carrières
qui n'auraient pas été intégralement
complète mais qui aurait connu pour la
majeure partie de la revalorisation au
moins 30 ans de cotisations
alors pour les carrés complexes c'est
100 euros
et ça permet de passer d'environ 1060
1060 euros aujourd'hui à
1170 euros aujourd'hui 1193 euros dans
nos prévisions en septembre ça me permet
de répondre indirectement à Madame Vogel
7 euros on sait que ça compte et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle vous
avez certainement noté que j'ai toujours
pris la précaution de dire une retraite
minimale une minimum près de 1200 euros
parce que je sais pertinemment qu'on
était plutôt autour de 1190 1193 non il
n'y a pas de dispositifs il y en a qu'un
articulé autour du minimum contributif
mais avec une revalorisation du myco
majoré pour 75 euros pour une carrière
complète cotise au niveau du SMIC et de
25 euros pour le minimum contributif
général de base pardon qui lui est plus
facilement accessible ce qui permet
d'amener des revalorisations à des
personnes qui ont des carrières très
incomplètes puisque non assujettiés
cette obligation de 120 trimestres
cotisés à l'échelle de l'année j'espère
avoir été
brut puisque la pension c'est 1200 euros
brut et c'est ainsi qu'on arrive à 1200
euros brut sur lequel s'applique le taux
de CSG tel que j'avais évoqué ensuite
dans Madame Vogel j'ai répondu sur le
prêt de 1200 euros et pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de confusion sur l'importance des 7
euros
oui mais elle avait aussi posé la
question des 7 euros voilà
sur sur les 1200 euros je ne sais pas le
dire précisément je sais que le système
que nous proposons ce que j'ai dit dans
mon propos liminaire permet de
revaloriser
la pension et la petite pension d'une
certaine manière de 200 000 nouveaux
assurés par an c'est-à-dire un départ
sur 4 pour un montant qui va varier de
25 ou 30 euros jusqu'à 100 euros mais je
n'ai pas la ventilation dont je préfère
en la matière ne pas vous donner un
chiffre trop précis qui serait pas
nature une erreur puisque je n'ai pas
cette ventilation avec moi à l'instant
où je vous parle madame la sénatrice m'a
demandé si je considérais que les
trimestres validé au titre de la
maternité provoquait un avantage induit
je pense qu'on peut avoir un débat très
apaisé sur la question des droits
familiaux et leur harmonisation en écho
à ce que j'ai dit à l'instant à Madame
l'humain sur les quatre trimestres
concernant la validation des trimestres
maternité sans être dans une forme de
caricature ou de procès d'intention il
n'y a pas davantage indus
il y a une situation que l'on peut dire
très calmement aussi et ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut la remettre en cause qui
est que la validation de 4 trimestres
pour les femmes à l'occasion d'une
maternité était pensé pour compenser des
trimestres non travaillés du fait de la
rédactivité et donc de l'arrêt de
cotisation le temps d'élever un enfant
est plutôt à l'échelle d'une année et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où pour une femme qui connaît
la maternité qui est indemnisé au titre
de l'assurance maladie pour le congé
maternité il y a finalement sur l'année
de naissance de l'enfant la possibilité
de valider quatre trimestres comme toute
personne en activité auquel s'ajoute de
valider et de cotiser qui est trimestre
auquel s'ajoute quatre trimestres de
majoration et auxquels peuvent s'ajouter
quatre trimestres supplémentaires
puisqu'on dit toujours 4 pour le régime
général mais en fait c'est 4 + 4 sachant
que les + 4 peuvent être répartis
librement entre les parents mais qu'à
défaut de répartition volontaire avant
les quatre ans de l'enfant ils sont
attribués automatiquement à la mer et
donc on est dans une situation nous
avons
cette différence d'âge effectif de
départ qui s'explique par le fait qu'à
carrière
du fait de validation trimestre
concomitant à la validation à la
cotisation de trimestre par activité il
y a une possibilité il y a une
possibilité nous constatons un départ
plus jeune des femmes par rapport aux
hommes et la réforme telle que nous
l'apportons à la fois par l'effet
qu'elle a et je souscris à la
démonstration sur ce point de Madame la
scénariste Vogel par le relèvement de
l'âge de départ mais aussi par la mise
en oeuvre de la réforme de 2013 amenant
une augmentation de la durée de
cotisation ces deux réformes conjuguées
font que il y aura un rapprochement de
l'âge effectif de départ et que la
différence de 6 mois que nous constatons
avec un âge de départ effectif des
femmes inférieur de celui des hommes de
6 mois va plutôt être autour de deux
mois à horizon 2030 c'est ce qui m'a
amené à dire cet après-midi que les
femmes ne travailleraient pas plus tard
ni plus longtemps que les hommes même
avec l'application de cette réforme et
cette réforme a aussi des effets en
termes de pension puisque pour la
génération 72 qui a été évoquée nous
estimons que le niveau moyen de
revalorisation des pensions permis par
la réforme de manière intrinsèque est au
tour de 650 euros par an et que 30% de
femmes environ d'assurer femme de femmes
assurées pardonnez-moi auront une
revalorisation de leur pension du fait
de la réforme et c'est justice quand on
sait l'écart de pension que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui enfin madame la
sénatrice avait une dernière question
sur les risques chimiques je fais vite
puisque là j'aurai l'occasion à mon avis
d'en reparler avec elle mais je voulais
évoquer avec elle les valeurs limites
d'exposition professionnelle telle que
définie par l'Union européenne qui pose
un cadre particulièrement protecteur et
auquel évidemment nous nous souscrivons
et dans lequel nous convergons
les départs anticipés pour incapacité ou
une aptitude sont plus importants
pourcentage et en volume que dans
d'autres métiers qu'ils soient public ou
privés et donc ça ne s'arrête pas un
milliard l'action pour la pénibilité ça
ne remet pas du tout en cause le fait
que la branche estmp puisse fonctionner
je disais tout à l'heure et je ne
partage pas votre inquiétude sur la
minoration des transferts vers la CNAM
mais dans les prévisions que nous avons
les 3,3 milliards d'excellents 2026 sont
après les transferts de 1 milliard un
milliard deux ça dépend des années qui
sont votés en PLFSS c'est 3 milliards 3
peuvent évidemment absorber 200 millions
d'euros par an de prévention pénibilité
et si nous diminuions de 1 milliard
d'euros il reste encore de milliards 2
milliards sur une branche qui gère 17
milliards d'euros sinon nous ne faisons
rien alors ça peut être vite comme très
bien mais peut-être inutile
si nous ne faisons rien de ce que nous
prévoyons la branche à TMP serait
excédentaire à hauteur de 20% de ses
recettes annuelles ce qui est un
excédent assez
inutile finalement en matière de
protection sociale il vaut mieux
mobiliser ses fonds pour pouvoir avancer
sur les interventions de madame poncemon
je tiens vous rassurer madame la
sénatrice les dépenses induites nous les
connaissons bien puisque tous les
chiffres que vous avez évoqués viennent
des services du ministère du travail
tant pour le chômage pour ce qui
concerne la DARES que pour la maladie
pour ce qui concerne l'adresse et dans
les mesures d'accompagnement que j'ai
évoquées
le fait de maintenir l'âge de départ à
taux plein sans décote à 62 ans pour les
personnes qui partent en capacité ou
inaptitude à 55 ans pour les
travailleurs handicapés c'est justement
ce qui nous permet d'éviter cet effet de
transfert que vous évoquez puisque dans
toutes les réformes précédentes et
c'était le cas de la réforme de 2010 le
relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture des
droits c'était accompagné d'un
relèvement de l'âge de départ sans
décote pour ses catégories de population
dites fragiles le fait de ne pas le
faire évite l'effet induits sur les
autres branches telles que nous avons pu
le constater dans le bilan d'application
de la réforme de 2010 et donc c'est
d'ores et déjà intégré dans notre
maquette notamment pour les questions
relatives au chômage et à l'assurance
maladie et je vous assure aussi nous
avons tenu compte de l'assiette et de
l'existence d'allègement en matière de
cotisation CNAV pour que la neutralité
soit bien présente dans un sens comme
dans l'autre et que ça ne coûte pas plus
aux employeurs mais que ça ne leur coûte
pas moins et enfin je termine madame la
Présidente mais j'ai répondu très
rapidement tout à l'heure pour dire à
Madame Jacquemet que la totalité de son
propos
concernant les pensions de réversion est
juste et que ça nécessite ce travail
très approfondi je forme simplement le
vœu que l'examen parlementaire nous
permet peut-être d'améliorer la
situation et la prise en compte de cette
situation moins nombreuses mais
peut-être très injuste je pense
notamment aux possibilités de
d'attribution de pension de réversion
aux orphelins en particulier aux
orphelins handicapés qui sont dans une
situation souvent dramatique et ça je
pense que nous pouvons trouver des
consensus et je l'espère les construire
sans attendre ce travail plus global sur
les droits familiaux que ce soit en
termes d'accompagnement de la maternité
de la parentalité et la question des
réversions pour répondre à des
situations plus compliquées que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui que l'on peut
réparer voilà je ne sais pas si j'ai
répondu absolument tout mais j'aurai
l'occasion je pense dans le débat de
revenir sur ces questions là
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci en
effet pour répondre de façon précise à
des questions complexes alors on peut ne
pas c'est le cas pour certains être
d'accord mais néanmoins nous vous
remercions de prendre le temps
nécessaire pour répondre de façon la
plus documentée possible à toutes les
questions que l'on vous pose et nous
vous donnons rendez-vous au débat
[Musique]